hey guys it sustained I'm here with my
sister Jenna and today we're recreating
one of my really old videos oh hi this
is in honor of national peanut butter
and jelly day I feel like it's your day
oh my god Jenna such a picky eater that
any time who go to restaurants she would
end up just eating a peanut butter and
jelly there because you or grilled
cheese so I thought today we would
dedicate this day to you
so is it what is today today is April
2nd should a peanut butter and jelly day
obviously ok I knew that this is the
video that we were gonna be recreating I
had a lot of peanut butter and jelly
back in the day and I did a lot of
things so take a quick look at what
we're gonna do
I've got two loaves of bread jelly jelly
peanut butter
you are very jelly let's do a real big
scoop this is a very heavy thing
it's looking real thick that's good
that's what we want oh my god this is
absolutely just it looks like vomit so
what I think I'm going to do is put a
big ol there this bread and just pour
this delicious liquid into it so this is
what we have so far yeah Adam do a very
good job of making us even but what I do
want to do is I want to seal it and just
dab it on the sides okay that's not
working at all let's see what happens
away pour the mix in yeah and see if we
can do it better this time
okay so first things that we're gonna
need for our peanut butter and jelly
sandwich tower is bread yes get a butter
jelly oh my gosh yeah get ripped we
needed like a knife or should I do
something inside understand here
well oh now we're gonna put this in here
okay so we're gonna first put in our
jelly what is the difference between
jelly and jam oh you don't know if I
knew I would be stating it as a fact and
not a question
does Tyler know Oh Tyler tell us jelly
ah wait jelly is doesn't have the stuff
in it
Jam has like the seeds and the pulp and
the this is my jam
no it's the truth we're telling the
truth oh the truth is in the pudding
watch this that's so your thumbs over my
mat hook this is gonna be like our Tower
so what we're gonna do we're going to
need to hollow out this bread trick it's
a drill okay
ask Justine from 2013 why she thought
this was a good idea I got a new pair of
pants I'm really excited about it why
did I do this I don't remember why I
need a circular thing this is like one
of the videos that really started my
Cooking Channel like I started cooking
slowly after this this expires February
2021 this is not outlast me okay so now
this is so we have to wash
so I think we might did you chew that
took money haha yeah are you eating it
see this has to be here so that that can
keep it in this uh no so when I did this
originally I'm not sure what I had in
mind I are you putting the bread in
there because we're gonna mix it up well
this bread is expired so what I just ate
some did you really did it taste okay
were you okay how are you feeling
because W was expired that's why I'm
using Eddie so here's the problem that I
ran into the last one is I really
thought that like this was structurally
going to hold always you never saw my
video from
[Music]
I'm just eating peanut butter okay that
looks good yeah take this peanut butter
yeah
and we're going to Genesis 2 I need you
to help it's not how you make a peanut
butter and jelly sandwich
oh I'm so sorry did you know everything
her to return / - no so I need to do
this to keep the juice inside this is
like my Redemption to make this work
this is disgust
I think my towers done final call let's
see what happened last time well I got
coming but I did this yeah what I do
what do I do
so we gotta do push it down a little
more
oh no we have a leak we have a leak we
have a leak Oh Mike here this is what
happens when you don't have a crow do
now I made a big mess and everything is
I hope let's just hope for this garbage
disposal works so that's what we did
here we go ready let me hold your sticks
for you this is gonna work oh my gosh
everything is working this is great oh
my goodness it only took me six yeah Oh
[Music]
how's it feelings I feel pretty steady
like there's no leaks we got to put the
jelly top in oh my god I'm covered well
I thought this was gonna be like no
icing yeah and I was gonna like doing a
pretty little okay so now we did that so
now what do we do oh because I feel like
if this is a very success it's starting
to get a little unsteady
welcome to 2009 is it gorgeous yeah it
is oh my god it is I know it's gonna no
no where's my knife this PBJ dick oh no
you want me to hold it like this
squeeze it back together oh well let's
squeeze it back together okay
no I'm yeah my I patched it looks like
if you would've let me squeeze in six
more years we'll try again
oh good 41 so wait here's the problem
left beautiful of it this way it still
looks good this looks
oh my god it looks like intestines that
have just spewed like it looks like he
looks like you just like boy I'm
disgusted thank you so much for
participating in the remake of one of my
old videos I want to do a couple more of
these there's so many of the videos that
I've watched my old videos I'm super
embarrassed by but I would love to do
remakes of them Shakira Shakira wait
it's not like she is our share wolf in
the closet
let's go away now well wait I don't want
to go away I want this to go away
I think I need of like I got to move
again
oh ye wait why are you bringing so much
here I can't just try to get out of this
okay
see you guys later we should have put an
egg in the middle
Oh should we have
[Music]
okay guys well thanks for watching um
let me know what you'd like to see me
fail at making next